The 2o of communication do not stop saying that the light
in January will rise 1 20%.
and the truth is that they are wrong.
It's going to be much worse and more attentive,
which no matter what company you are in.
I explain the 4 reasons,
1,
VAT will rise from 5% to 21%.
2,
the electricity tax will be increased from 0.5 to 5,
there you have that 20%.
But the 2 worst are missing,
the rise in electric tolls,
both potential and energy,
you will notice this
because it is multiplied by power and consumption.
and it will be quite noticeable.
In 4th place,
the new law
which will start in 2024 for the regulatory market.
If you want to start paying as little as possible right away,
for when this change comes
that costs you as little as possible,
go to my profile and click on this link